[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuántos de ustedes tienen ocho o diez
años viviendo en juárez
levanten la mano guau excelente yo tengo
un poquito más de 40 años viviendo un
poquito nada más
ciudad juárez para mí es una ciudad una
frontera extraordinaria
a pesar de que mis padres tuvieron la
decisión de que naciera en otro país
aunque estaba cruzando el charco de
juárez
fue algo impactante en mi vida porque
cuando era niña porque yo me sentía
mexicana
en todos los sentidos tenía imágenes de
un tío que era general del ejército y
pues imagínense todas sus vivencias
todas sus aventuras todo lo que hacía
por el país me hacían sentir honrada
y aparte al escuchar el himno nacional o
hacer el saludo a la bandera me hacía
sentir orgullosamente mexicana a pesar
de haber nacido en el vaso frías
uno de los lugares más maravillosos
que tuve la experiencia de vivir desde
niña fue el parque el chamizal porque
porque mis papás me llevaban a pasear a
convivir un tiempo con la familia con
los amigos y era una sensación y una
experiencia padrísima porque porque está
en la naturaleza estaba seguro la gente
riendo y como pasó el tiempo tuve la
oportunidad que me regalaron una
bicicleta que en la verdad mis padres no
querían porque era muy peligroso ellos
trabajaban y era difícil poder beber y a
ver qué hacía efectivamente si van a
trabajar llegar a la escuela para mi
bicicleta y viva el chamizal
a la unidad
que estaba muy peligrosa para mi edad
que tenía 910 años ahorita está aquí mi
mamá yo creo ya se está dando cuenta de
lo que hacía cuando ella no estaba pero
era un escape porque me encantaba el
parque el chamizal y era una manera de
disfrutar algo que me apasionaba la
bicicleta
quiero saber qué hacían ustedes
en el año 2006 al 2011
me imagino que hacían las cosas que
todos hacemos trabajar
ir a la escuela ir al mandado
etcétera
sería una oportunidad de ir a un bar con
sus amigos
a un restaurant con su familia
o salían a la calle a correr oa llevar a
sus hijos a un parque no importará la
hora
creo que esto último no era posible
porque vivíamos en ese tiempo en una
cárcel dentro de nuestras casas porque
nada más hacíamos lo necesario para
salir adelante la escuela el trabajo
comprar comida a la casa no salgas día
tarde porque no sabemos que puedan pasar
a mí lo personal me pasaba que lleva el
trabajo encontraba con situaciones
desagradables
y era muy impactante para mí y me
impactó tanto que
quería hacer algo por juárez pero no
sabía cómo se me hacía algo muy difícil
y hacer un cambio yo elsa por la ciudad
como estaba en ese momento
era muy complicado en este momento para
mí pensar qué hacer pero tenía ese
pensamiento porque veía mi ciudad
lastimada y no la quería ver así la
amaba
y no quería que estuviera así
en ese tiempo en un periodo de dos años
y medio más de 5000 personas fueron
asesinadas principalmente jóvenes de 14
a 24 años
porque porque se unían al narcotráfico
por 45 dólares a la semana
mucha gente salió de juárez
aproximadamente 400.000 se fueron a la
ciudad del vaso se fueron a sus lugares
de origen
negocios quebraron totalmente por todo
lo que había extorsiones asaltos y
asesinatos
en ese ir y pensar de ideas
pues quería yo hacer algo pero no sabía
exactamente que cuando era niña
soñaba con ir a las olimpiadas yo jugaba
basquetbol y era mi pasión y yo jugaba y
entrenaba porque era mi pasión un día mi
papá me dijo hija
creo que jugar basquetbol para ir a las
olimpiadas va a ser muy difícil y siendo
mujer más
te recomiendo mejor que piensas en el
atletismo y sería más fácil que pudieras
despuntar y pudiera decir a las
olimpiadas pero a mí el correr
se me hacía parte de un deporte no se me
hacía un deporte encima y pues no le
hice caso si jugando por más de 30 años
básquetbol hasta que un día te lesiones
y yo creo que vino la luz hace 7 años en
el 2011 aproximadamente
decidí a empezar a correr
y en ese momento quería tener adquirí a
hacer algo diferente
y va próxima a cumplir 40 años
yo creo ya saben cuántos 45
y dije mi cumple hay un número 40 quiero
correr un maratón pero un maratón es
algo que nunca había hecho lo más que
había corrido son diez kilómetros diez
mil metros con el 42.1 sería algo
demasiado entonces empecé mezclar que
podía hacer para entrenarme y en esa
búsqueda encontré que había un maratón
en la ciudad de chicago eeuu casi el día
de mi cumpleaños dije este es este lo va
a tomar y éste lo va a correr y lo
decidí tenía mi mente mi meta muy clara
en mi mente así que me proyecté para eso
empecé a buscar programas en internet
porque pues quién me va a ayudar más que
yo
en ese ínter pues tenía miedos porque
empecé a escuchar y leer que de personas
les daba un paro cardíaco por por este
practicar el maratón y terminarlo
entonces decían guau
tengo que hacer unos estudios tengo que
ver cómo ando si no tengo anemia si mi
corazón está bien está listo para correr
ese reto y efectivamente estaba
excelente para poder correr lo empecé a
entrenar vinieron lesiones
los nervios venían porque paraba de
correr pero no mi meta mi meta siempre
estaba ahí
llegó el momento el día 7 de octubre en
1902 el 2012 perdón
cuando era la fecha del maratón me
acompañó mi madre que creo que estaba
más nerviosa que yo porque hasta traía
su monitor cardíaco para ver si me lo
iba a necesitar en un momento verdad y
trataba de estar calmada porque sabía
que ella se ponía más nerviosa
llegué al lugar de la salida en una
emoción tan grande que no podía
describir eran aproximadamente las
40.000 personas corriendo y no podía
creer que tantas personas pudieran hacer
esto empecé a correr motivada contenta
feliz
con mis audífonos hoy escuchando música
mexicana pero llegó un momento en lo que
me lo tuve que quitar porque porque la
gente me gritaba méxico gméxico entonces
cuando me gritaron así dije guau este es
un regalo la música nos sirve y porque
me gritaban méxico como sabían que el
sas era de méxico porque trae una
playera que traía verde blanco y rojo a
la bandera y decía méxico
entonces de este momento sentí que
estaba cumpliendo mi sueño ir a las
olimpiadas
me sentía extraordinariamente feliz
pasado el camino llegué al kilómetro 26
y empecé a sentir una molestia en el
pecho pero muy fuerte que dije se me
hace que es mi corazón
se me hace que tengo que parar
no puedo seguir porque me duele mucho y
después ya no pero está haciendo frío
estoy sudando puede ser por eso después
de eso me empezó a doler el tobillo que
no es una señal que debo de parar dios
me está diciendo para por qué te duele
todo todo todo todo pero también pensé
dije me estoy saboteando me estoy yo
misma diciendo no puedes y no vas a
poder
en ese ínter estar luchando con las
cosas
que venían en mi mente
llegué al kilómetro 31
el kilómetro 31 de la calle pilsen
porque lo recuerdo
porque desde un kilómetro antes
se oye una música muy conocida
y esa música era mexicana
era el pueblo mexicano era el barrio
mexicano que estaba ya apoyando a los
maratonistas
al llegar a ese punto
mis lágrimas salieron de la emoción mi
voz se quebró sentía que en mi piel se
erizaba
mi garganta se hizo un nudo que no podía
ni hablar
olía enchiladas olía gorditas o la
comida de mexico la música había títeres
gigantes
la gente vestida con trajes regionales
decía guau éste es vigente
y seguí llorando en lo que iba que
llorando y caminando me toque un señor y
me dices paisana
ya hizo todo lo que pudo hacer para
llegar aquí es falta poquito usted puede
es una campeona en este momento nada más
le dice con la cara cabeza que sí porque
no podía ni hablar
me fui corriendo mi dolor del pecho se
me quitó mi dolor del tobillo se me
quitó y siento que corrí más su precio
más ágil
en ese momento pensé en juárez en todos
mis pensamientos que se me venían mi
familia mis amigos
proyectos que iba a ser porque se te
abre tu mente pero en eso no se quitaba
la idea de juárez juárez
qué puedo hacer por juárez de tanto que
pensé en tiempo atrás que podía hacer en
ese momento se me vino la idea de hacer
un equipo de corredores en el que el
niños adultos jóvenes hasta perritos que
se agregarán en este grupo y poder
ayudarles a tener una visión diferente
como porque trabajando en equipo creando
planes podemos hacer cosas diferentes
podemos crear y podemos salir adelante
así fue hasta que casi llegando a la
meta todo el miedo
qué sentida de la sensación de ver a mi
ciudad lastimada
se eliminó porque llegué a la meta en 4
horas 42 minutos y recibí esto
esta medalla que me hizo sentir que era
lo mejor que había ganado el primer
lugar que había luchado por conseguir
esto que era muy difícil lograrlo
y lo logré si podría hacer esto podría
hacer cualquier cosa si yo me lo
proponía y si lo tenía aquí
así fue en ese momento que cruce la meta
lloré y ya dije ya sé que un hombre va a
tener mi equipo se va a llamar jrc está
running team que significa juárez
running team
llegué feliz me sentía extraordinaria
porque había haber logrado dos cosas
hacer algo por mi ciudad y ser
maratonista
en ese interior llegando a juárez tuve
una reunión con unas amigas en la cual
me celebraron y cumpleaños y platiqué mi
historia vivida en el maratón
al contarle se emocionaron tanto que
dijeron sabes que elsa yo quiero estar
en ese equipo yo quiero ser parte de eso
y su amiga también era claudia y
josefina
hicimos el equipo en una semana teníamos
el logo playeras hicimos planes para
casi un año
se apuntaron para hacer una carrera en
marzo del 2013 nunca habían corrido
entonces fue algo muy importante porque
empezamos a mover a participar en
carreras locales la gente nos veía
porque nos veía porque nos disfrazábamos
nos poníamos disfraces la gente se
emocionaba entonces eso causó que la
gente se agregara a más a más al equipo
primeramente fueron mujeres amas de casa
estudiantes después se empezaron a
agregar jóvenes chicos y hasta perros
tenemos una infinidad de personas tanto
niños jóvenes adultos señoras que
empiezan desde cero no necesitan correr
o ser corredores profesionales
durante estos cinco años que hemos
formado el equipo hemos hecho grandiosas
cosas como hacer carreras de labor
social en la ciudad de gran calidad y
todo lo que recabamos lo donamos a
instituciones civiles a deportistas que
necesitan también
y uniformes o equipo deportivo
también hemos tenido la oportunidad de
ir a congresos en los cuales también nos
especializamos en entrenamiento tenemos
coaches que nos ayudan a salir adelante
y eso ha sido que el grupo crezca con
más de 600 corredores que usan esta
armadura porque no es una playera porque
cuando la ponemos somos invencibles
nos sentimos juarenses y la
representamos en todos los lugares que
vamos hemos participado en muchos
maratones tanto locales nacionales e
internacionales que han hecho que cuando
nos ven no pueden creer que somos de
ciudad juárez la ciudad que fue
lastimada la ciudad donde matan mujeres
decía no podemos creer que usted estén
aquí pero si estamos aquí
uno de los casos que les quisiera contar
cómo ha impactado a
a la gente que ha entrado al equipo
cambiando sus vidas cambiando sus
hábitos
y saliendo de un estado emocional
difícil que os va a contar de noemí una
compañera que perdió su hijo por cáncer
su vida cambió totalmente
y al cambiar su vida
cambió su entorno su familia su
matrimonio eso afectó tanto en su vida
que no quería salir que no quería hacer
nada le invitaron al equipo empezó a ver
que todos teníamos metas que empezamos
desde cero
llegó un momento en que noemí no sólo
fue corredora fue nadadora fue ciclista
y hoy en día ha ganado muchas
competencias tiene 58 años y se acaba de
graduar de enfermera se motivo tanto que
ha hecho grandes cosas después de esto
otro caso es alfredo que recibe tuvo
varios infartos y también se unió al
grupo porque quería correr con alguien
porque se sentía que no podía él solo y
eso le ayudó a
a tener retos y a poder
lograr correr por competencias que jamás
pensó a pesar de la situación que él
creía que no podía ahorita tiene un
marcapaso que le acaban de poner hace
como un año sigue corriendo y es feliz
porque le apasiona
les cuento todo esto porque porque
fueron ignacio a un grupo en el cual ha
impactado a muchas personas a muchísimas
y no tanto como a ellos también en salud
en retos gente que ha llegado
corriendo caminando ahora son
maratonistas ultramaratonistas y eso nos
enorgullece mucho de que podemos hacer
algo por juárez porque juárez tiene
gente con mucho valor con mucho corazón
buenos profesionistas artistas
y hoy los invito a ustedes
a que se unan a hacer algo por su ciudad
teniendo en el objetivo en su mente
pueden lograr grandes cosas haciendo las
cosas con pasión
podemos lograr muchas cosas para ti por
ti para todos y gracias a ti así que los
invito a que se unan por su ciudad que
hagamos algo yo tengo el compromiso en
seguir corriendo inspirando más gente
invitándolos al equipo
soy juan ruano
[Aplausos]